THAT’S THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT’S
"ANGLE"."
TODAY’S LEFTISTS ARE NOTHING
LIKE THE LIBERALS OF EVEN TEN
YEARS AGO.
AND THEY’VE TOTALLY TAKEN OVER
THE DEMOCRAT PARTY.
THEY ARE CALLING ALL THE SHOTS.
NO ONE EVEN BOTHERS TRYING TO
STOP THEM.
HANNITY JUST REFERENCED THAT.
WHETHER THEY ARE DESTROYING
PRIVATE OR PUBLIC PROPERTY.
LOCAL AND STATE AUTHORITIES, ALL
DEMOCRATS HERE, THEY COWER WHEN
THE BIRKENSTOCK BOLSHEVIKS
OCCUPY HUGE SLOTS OF A CITY LIKE
SEATTLE.
HAVE A SCENT FREE VEGAN PIZZAS
TO ALL OF THE ANGRY SQUATTERS
YET?
I’M EXPECTING THAT.
EXTRA PAIRS OF SKINNY JEANS,
FOOT SCRUBS, SALT SCRUBS.
WEIGHT, BY THE WAY, THESE
VIDEOS, I THOUGHT THEY WERE
AGAINST HOARDERS.
THERE NOTHING ABOUT THE SPONGE
THAT IS LIBERAL, BECAUSE THE OLD
FREE SPEECH MOVEMENT AT BERKELEY
IN 1964 AND WAS DEVOTED TO
REVERSING THE PROHIBITION
ACTIVITIES ON CAMPUS.
NOW, DON’T GET ME WRONG, THEY
WERE RADICAL, BUT AT LEAST THEY
ACTUALLY BELIEVED IN FREE
EXPRESSION.
I THINK THEY GENERALLY LIKE THE
COUNTRY.
WELL, NOT SO WITH THE
NEO-MARXISTS OF TODAY.
THEY ARE SLEDGEHAMMER AND
STATUES AND SMEARING ANYONE WHO
DOESN’T BOW DOWN, OPEN THEIR
WALLETS, OR MAKE A CONFESSIONAL
ON SOCIAL MEDIA.
THESE PERFORMANCE ACTIVISTS WHO
HAVE MARINATED AND
ANTI-AMERICANISM ONLINE AND IN
THE CLASSROOM, THEY DON’T
BELIEVE IN FREE SPEECH OR
FREEDOM OF WORSHIP, OR EVEN
ACADEMIC FREEDOM FOR ANYONE WHO
DISAGREES WITH THEM.
THEY’VE NEVER REALLY LEARNED
ANYTHING IN-DEPTH AND POSITIVE
ABOUT THE CONSTITUTION.
MAY BE BESIDES THAT IT WAS --
WELL, THEY LEARNED IT WAS AGREED
TO AND WRITTEN BY A BUNCH OF
OLD, DEAD, WHITE GUYS.
THUS, HISTORY MEANS NOTHING TO
THESE FOLKS.
FREE INQUIRY MEANS NOTHING TO
THEM.
THEY WANT TROPHIES, MAY BE,
MOUNTED ON THE WALL, THOUGH,
HEADS OF OLD CONFEDERATE
GENERALS OR PINK SLIPS FOR
ACADEMICS WHO DEFY THEM.
A CORNELL LAW PROFESSOR’S
WEBSITE DARED CRITIQUE BLM IS
NOW UNDER SIEGE FROM A MOB OF
ANGRY LEFT-WINGERS.
ONE STUDENT COMPLAINED HIS
ARTICLES WERE "HURTFUL AND
DIVISIVE."
THE PROFESSOR IS GOING TO JOIN
US LATER IN THE HOUR.
NOW, LAST NIGHT, A SIMILAR STORY
OUT OF UCLA, ALTHOUGH A
DIFFERENT CULTURE CRIME WAS
ALLEGED IN THE PROFESSOR IN THE
CROSSHAIRS, GORDON KLEIN, HAS
TAUGHT BUSINESS CLASSES THERE
FOR 39 YEARS.
HE ISSUED THIS STARK WARNING TO
AMERICANS ABOUT THE STATE OF
EDUCATION TODAY IN AMERICA.
>> I WAS USED TO SACRIFICE WHEN
THEY ARE WEIGHING THE PRINCIPAL
OF STANDING ON THE QUALITY OF
TREATMENT FOR ALL STUDENTS,
IRRESPECTIVE OF COLOR, VERSUS
TRYING TO PLACATE THE ANGRY MOB.
IT IS ABSOLUTELY A SET SAD DAY F
FREE INQUIRY.
>> Laura: A SIMILAR THING, BY
THE WAY, PLAYING OUT IN THE
UNIVERSITY OF CHICAGO, I JUST
TWEETED ABOUT IT A FEW MINUTES
AGO.
THIS IS A SUSTAINED CAMPAIGN OF
PERSONAL DESTRUCTION, THAT’S ALL
IT IS.
THE MARXISTS AREN’T INTERESTED
IN DEBATES, NOT INTERESTED IN
RECONCILIATION, CERTAINLY NOT
INTERESTED IN COMPROMISE.
THEY AREN’T UP AT NIGHT WORRYING
ABOUT CULTIVATING PEACE OR
SPREADING PROSPERITY TO YOU.
THEY CARE ABOUT POWER.
GETTING IT, AND KEEPING IT.
THEY WANT TOTAL AND COMPLETE
SUBMISSION FROM ANY INSTITUTIONS
WHERE THEY CAN GAIN LEVERAGE TO
ADVANCE THEIR GOAL OF A FULL
TAKEOVER OF AMERICAN LIFE, AND
I’M TALKING EVERY ASPECT OF IT.
REMEMBER WHEN OBAMA SAID YOU
DIDN’T BUILD THAT?
WELL, TODAY’S RADICALS BELIEVE
THE ONLY REASON YOU OWN PROPERTY
IS BECAUSE YOU TOOK IT UNFAIRLY
FROM SOMEONE ELSE, OR YOU GOT IT
BY EXERCISING YOUR WHITE
PRIVILEGE.
AND WHEN YOU THINK THAT EVERY
AMERICAN IS LIVING ON STOLEN
LAND, AS THEY DO, WE COULD AND
EVIL, WELL, WHY SHOULDN’T
EVERYTHING BE BURNED DOWN?
WHY SHOULDN’T IT’S HISTORY BE
LEVELED?
IF IT MEANS THEY HAVE TO
THREATEN COMPANIES TO GET THEIR
MONEY AND COOPERATION, THEY’LL
DO IT.
IF IT MEANS THAT THEY TARGET
INDIVIDUALS THROUGH
INTIMIDATION, THEY’LL DO IT.
IF IT MEANS USING THE HORRIFIC
DEATH OF SOMEONE LIKE GEORGE
FLOYD TO MARKET A VICIOUS HATRED
OF ALL LAW ENFORCEMENT, THEY’LL
DO IT, AND THEY DID IT.
THE FAMILY OF OFFICER SHAYNA
COLONUS OF NEVADA KNOWS JUST HOW
SERIOUS THESE NEO-MARXISTS ARE.
HE WAS SHOT IN THE HEAD LAST
WEEK WHILE WORKING THE PROTESTS
IN LAS VEGAS.
DOCTORS NOW EXPECT HIM TO BE ON
A VENTILATOR FOR THE REST OF HIS
LIFE.
HE’S ONLY 29.
DEFUNDING THE POLICE WILL MEAN
MORE VIOLENCE, FEWER OFFICERS TO
RESPOND, AND MORE CARNAGE.
>> THERE IS A REAL OPPRESSION
AND DANGER TO OUR COMMUNITIES
MORE FROM VIOLENT CRIME AND
LAWLESSNESS THAN IT DOES FROM
THE POLICE.
>> Laura: THAT WAS BILL BARR
TODAY IN DALLAS WITH THE
PRESIDENT, AND AN AMAZING PANEL.
OF COURSE, PRESIDENT TRUMP
UPSETS TODAY’S ILL LIBERAL
ELITES WHEN HE TWEETS THINGS
LIKE LAW AND ORDER FOR A SHORT
TWEET.
HE’S NOT SENSITIVE ENOUGH THEY
SAY, THEY HAVE TO BE MORE
SENSITIVE.
ON THE CONTRARY.
LAW AND ORDER IS WHAT ALL OF OUR
CITIZENS DESERVE, THAT IS BEING
SENSITIVE.
NOT JUST, BY THE WAY, THE ONES
RICH ENOUGH TO AFFORD PERSONAL
PRIVATE PROTECTION, PRESEEMS
OVERRUN.
THE CONSERVATIVISM OF TRUMP IS
DEDICATED TO IMPROVING THE LIVES
OF ALL AMERICANS, BLUE-COLLAR,
LOW INCOME, ENTREPRENEURS OF ALL
BACKGROUNDS AND ALL RACES AND
CREEDS.
STOP BEING THE ENDLESS WAR,
FORCING CHINA TO COME TO THE
BARGAINING TABLE WITH TARIFFS,
STRENGTHENING OUR BORDERS,
ELIMINATING ONEROUS REGULATIONS,
THESE WERE ALL REAL ACTIONS THAT
REAP HUGE RESULTS COME UNTIL THE
COVID SHUTDOWN.
IMAGINE A U.S. LED BY
PRESIDENT JOE BIDEN.
WHO YOU KNOW WILL JUST MELT FOR
THE MAKI AUTO MARXISTS.
IMAGINE ALL THE OLD STATUES, THE
MONUMENTS, ALL THOSE OFFENDING
FLAGS -- THEY ARE ALL GONE.
ALL POLITICALLY INCORRECT SONGS
AND MOVIES PULLED.
ALL WORKPLACES, ALL CLASSROOMS
WILL ENFORCE SPEECH CODES.
POLICE DEPARTMENTS WILL BE
DEFUNDED OR DISBANDED.
IMAGINE ALL THAT HAS TAKEN
PLACE.
THEN WHAT?
HOW DOES ANY OF THAT CREATE JOBS
FOR THE LEAST AMONG US?
FOR ANYBODY?
HOW DOES ANY OF THAT RAISE
WAGES?
HOW DOES ANY OF THAT MAKE OUR
NEIGHBORHOOD SAFER?
HOW WILL IT IMPROVE RACE
RELATIONS?
PATRONIZING SYMBOLS OR GESTURES
MIGHT FEEL GOOD IN THE MOMENT,
BUT THEY DON’T END UP PUTTING
FOOD ON THE TABLE OR PAYING YOUR
KIDS TUITION BILLS.
A GOOD PAYING JOB DOES, THOUGH.
IT’S OBVIOUS RIGHT NOW THAT AN
ALLIANCE OF MEDIA, POLITICAL,
AND RADICAL FORCES ARE TRYING TO
DEMORALIZE MILLIONS OF
LAW-ABIDING AMERICANS WHO
BELIEVE IN EQUALITY AND JUSTICE
FOR ALL, AND WHO ALSO SUPPORT
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
THEY WANT YOU TO THINK THAT ALL
HOPE IS LOST.
IF THEY WANT YOU TO THINK THAT
AMERICA’S BEST DAYS ARE OVER.
THEY WANT TO STOP TRUMP’S
RALLIES, AND EVEN USE A VIRUS
THREAT TO KEEP YOU OUT OF CHURCH
AND SEPARATED FROM YOUR FAMILY
AND FRIENDS.
WELL, TONIGHT, I SAY DON’T LET
’EM.
DON’T GIVE INTO THIS CAMPAIGN OF
DEMORALIZATION.
THESE ARE SOME OF THE MOST
RACIALLY POLARIZING, VINDICTIVE
PEOPLE ON THE FACE OF THE
PLANET, AND THEY HAVE NO RIGHT
TO LECTURE YOU, AND NO RIGHT TO
TAKE AWAY YOUR VOICE.
WE DO SUBSTANCE, THEY DO
SYMBOLISM.
THEY BURN STUFF DOWN.
WE ARE BUILDING IT UP.
WE ARE A FREE PEOPLE, AND WE ARE